hello everyone and welcome to building
data Lake on GC pinta my name is Nathan
Moore key I'm a product manager in the
data analytics role
so today we're going to be talking about
how you build data leaks but let us
first understand what a deal makers data
Lake is fertilized and a secure data
platform for ingesting storing
processing and analyzing all your data
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data at scale when we work
with our customers we find out that the
traditional approach for building data
waves where you bring data from various
different sources and land them into one
single central store has not worked and
has not provided good results and they
have also told us that they would like
to have more in use case driven dynamics
right so the traditional approach
basically ended up creating instead of
lakes it ended up creating swamps and
too much of you know operational cost
was incurred there in maintaining those
lakes but when you look at like what
those data lakes are and what is the
value proposition of having a data rate
there are many one of them to begin with
is cost sales you sing a lot of
operational and capital costs and
essentially doing all of these
transformations outside of your
traditional data warehouse it also
increases the quality of the data right
as the data actually gets processed in
the lake the quality of the data as it
progresses to the lake increases
dramatically now if you build a good
data Lake it has to have a fast
discovery mechanism which will allow you
to identify all kinds of data that
exists within the Nick right and then
when you think about what actually this
data Lake is going to provide to you
it's going to reduce the times of
analytics it's going to basically make
it easier for doing analytics that you
would be able to do it before and with
expeditions you are able to get to
market faster now there are different
components there in world and building
away that it is you are doing a data
discovery you're organized
transformations your optimizations there
are various different components that
have to be included together to build
the best dinner now let's see what are
some of the challenges that are there in
building the IBM data leak solution
dynamics are complex and time-consuming
right at the process of building them
and managing them is extremely difficult
and the reasons for these things to be
difficult is because you are doing a lot
of various different operations within
the light first of then that you begin
with is importing an ingesting data it's
a very laborious process we have to
first identify all of the various
different data sources that exists in
within your organization which could be
of various different formats and various
different data sources that you would
have to bring all that data together
using some form of an ingestion - now
once you land a line in the light you
have to organize it and if you can't
organize it very well it just turns up
into a swamp so you have to spend huge
amounts of time organizing the data in
the link so it is basically you
categorize the data in various segments
you basically store them separate them
segregate them and also assign different
security policies but the next thing
that is critically important in the lake
is data transformations the data
transformation provides the standardized
way of transforming the data from the
wrong amount of standardized form and
then actually preparing them for
analytics now we'll combine all of these
things together the most important part
that you bring all of the LEDs didn't
reach is the discovery if there exists
no good discovery mechanism anomaly the
data itself is lost and it turns into a
dark data and more such dark data
actually leads to creating a swamp
rather than a lake that you would like
to have and the quality aspect of a data
layer is critically important from few
reasons one if you look at traditionally
why did Alex well Phil didn't expect
personally a lot of wood that
happening in the data warehouse so that
they could use the CPU cycles of the
data warehouse to run the queries so
with you bring all of that data in and
combine that with all of the structured
unstructured and semi-structured data
put together you have to have a very
cohesive strategy for ensuring the
quality of the data as it progresses
through the data leak towards the data
warehouse or data Mart
so there has to be tools that have to be
integrated in order to have guaranteed
data quality for the data moving through
the Waverly last but not the least you
want to live but you don't want and a
lady that is not accessible for babies
from various different boots but the
bare open source tools whether they're
proprietary tools it doesn't matter but
it has to be accessible to all kinds of
tools that exist within the ecosystem so
interoperability plays a very vital role
in ensuring that your daily lives are
not isolated so let's go to three
primary pillars on which relates m01
ability to put link builder links which
is essentially morning populating data
from various different sources in the
delay once you bring the data into the
lake you need to be able to capture all
that data you need to be able to
discover them you need to make it easy
to find all of the data that exists in
the link right so you have to have some
kind of an ability to crawl all of that
metadata that exist within the MIDI and
so that into a simple central repository
once the data is law it has to be easily
discoverable through search my hands now
once a lot of different types of
metadata that you connected one is file
format the other would be various
different metadata associated with it
the size of it at the time the date it
was updated so all the metadata
associated with the data have can be
aggregated with this category the next
is standardized in cleansing the deer so
I have the data lines in the lake the
data has to be cleansed it has to be
into it has to be standardized and it
has to canonicalize to confirm to
standard format that is appropriate for
the organisation things like SSN things
like phone numbers things like zip codes
all these have to be processed in a
standard fashion and they have to be
really easy to do that right so the all
these transformations takes a large
amount of time so these things have to
be simplified as part of the process so
you wouldn't want to have some kind of a
code free tool that will allow you to do
that
now now that you have brought the data
into the lake the first thing you want
to do is secure that data you want to be
able to define access control and you
also want to not really just do it on
the data but also the applications that
are going to be accessing that data it's
quickly important it's data access
control is one aspect of the cases that
are going to be accessing the data also
have to be controlled now in a way there
are so many different jobs that are done
right jobs that ingesting the real jobs
that are standardizing in the transfer
making it and preparing it for analytics
to parity for warehouses now all this in
an enterprise are based on a scheduled
time window during which these jobs have
to be executed so in order to get a
better insight into you into those
metrics you would have to have ability
to understand all of the different
metrics that are there you have to have
access to them as well as being able to
look at the end-to-end assembly of the
jobs some kind of a - like a data
operations dashboard is required to
enable these now because lay is a simple
place where you know critical data
exists and as you all know of all the
data that is in the late 20% of the data
is actually very critical and it's being
used by a lot of different parts of the
organization so in order to ensure good
security mechanism
compliance mechanism that needs to exist
other clubs that administrator can use
to see and improve the access control as
well as the security for the data right
now what you have ingested the data and
you have provided the standardization
tools to essentially transform the data
and you have secured the next thing
which is critically important for a lake
is to making the lake accessing right
the lake today is being if it is not
accessible to the world or the pools
outside people will not find the lake
usable so first of all the Linux should
be able to expose all of the data that
it has in various different tools
whether you are using spark or the V you
are using hi there is you presto you're
using bigquery it doesn't matter if the
data that sits in the lake has to be
immediately be accessible to proprietary
as well as open source tools in addition
to that the data has to be you know
smartly partition because what ends up
happening is as there are various
different tools and various different
needs from an optimization perspective
the data has to be partitioned in such a
way that it is you know integrate seemly
the seamlessly with all of these
different tools and there is like from
an analytics improvements there needs to
be handling of partitioning of the data
which actually is very critical ways of
moving data from various different areas
within because you can call them zones
radius different zones within the lake
that you define
there needs to be a standardized to be
moving that data because in some cases
you might want to move the data from the
final you know the defined zone directly
into into your dear warehouse so in
having the ability which is in build and
allowing you to connect with the world
outside is critical if it is extremely
critical for making the make successful
with these three simple pillars you can
build an end
now there are many use cases that can
use this late and let's briefly look at
the kinds of use cases that we have seen
with our customers and how they are
actually using all of the GCP products
and bringing them together in the
induced cases let's start with the
simple nuisance
first of all data warehouse staging and
this was the primary purpose for which
the alleged editor they wanted to
offload all of the additional ELT the
the transformation that happens in the
warehouse they wanted to offload it in
Linux so that it provides a lot of cost
savings and then they have more
horsepower in the warehouse to run
analytical queries now will you bring
that into the link what needs to be
happening is the lake has to define
these zooms or staging areas right so
there are different staging areas that
have to be defined so customers end up
defining various different staging areas
where the data may not strong they bring
all of the raw data from external
systems with it a structured
semi-structured or unstructured data
into a Rasta j-- then they will
transform them but cleanse it
standardized it can analyze it and move
it into a refined stage now once the
data is another fine stage they will run
further analysis they will apply
business rules people again for the
cleanse the data based on business rules
that they have from their organization
and then they move it into a curated
stage then ending up into the data
warehouse so this is a very simple use
case in most common use case that we see
on GCP right now let's look at the next
one which is literally a rapes are used
from from a perspective of their science
experimentation so it follows a similar
model but here the data the curated data
now has to be accessible to exploratory
tools things like you know you want to
have access you want to provide access
to notebooks you want to provide access
to any of the other machine learning
tools that exists you want to have
access from this path like all the data
that is actually in the curated zone has
to be made accessible
all of these different tools that exist
within open-source and there are more
that keeps on getting added
year-over-year right so this is the
second use case that we commonly see on
how people are using data makes
anticipate the last one is an
interesting use case and this has been
this is recently becoming more popular
where customers are using the data and
transforming it moving it into data
warehouse but also they are looking at
ways where they can take the data from
the data warehouse and put it back into
the lake and then have a federated way
of querying the data between the data
warehouse and the capability that allows
you to bring the data state data or
world Inga and the new data combined
together when you're essentially doing
ad hoc analysis of analysis that you're
looking to write so all these three use
cases are primarily what we Jen what we
see with our customers on GCP now when
you look at what goes into building
these three use cases right that's these
are the components of GCP that makes
them happen right now we have various
different services and these services
have to be brought together and this is
something that we will be looking in the
future but these are some of the things
that you would have to pick together in
order to build your link so right now
it's do-it-yourself like and this is
going to be you know we are looking at
how we will be integrating these various
different components to make it easier
for you but in order to build them later
there are two main things you need from
a big perspective first is you need the
central storage you need to have the
ability to store the data whether it's
structured semi-structured or
unstructured data you need to have a way
to store them and part of GCB there are
two services that are available one is
Google Cloud storage and the other is a
big credit storage so these provide and
we look at what those differences are
and when you should be using one over
the other I mean it's an easy choice but
it would like to give you more
information
so storage is vital
the second one is security you need to
be able to have the best security
possible for securing all of the data
that actually exists with it on a big
query side cloud storage side so close
storage provides you a bucket level or
the prefix level access control that you
can define and set on these policies
that you can set and it has now I think
we have added like column level as well
as row level security as part of a big
way so customers can pick and choose how
they want evade they want the people
like to be and what the detail is
storage is but these are the two common
choices that customers make when they
are critically now when you look at how
you bring the data into the way there
are various different services if you
are bringing data in real time customers
tend to use pops up and when you're
looking to move massive amounts of data
from your on trend filers to GCP
directly they end up using what we call
transfer appliance transfer appliances
you can order them they will come to
your data centers you can copy it into
it and ship it back and then it will be
copied into the buckets that you have
created for for this data then you have
the efficient as another tool that
allows you to bring the capabilities
that exist within the query which are
tied to bigquery from that perspective
to make you transfer service that allows
you to bring from all of the various
different sources into big right now the
data has as is being ingested in it
needs to be catalogued so by default
right now all of the data that exists
the doones bigquery automatically gets
registered with tilaka clock but GCS
there is no mechanism right now by which
the cheesiest minute GCS data the data
that gets stored on GCS get scheduled
automatically so you would have to end
up building some kind of
I'm not really that excited that's
looking at all of the different buckets
and different files that exist within
GCS bucket and registering them with the
capital so that's that's something that
we would have to build by yourself
right now so you would have to use and
you know your favorite - programming
language of choice to build and
capability to I have metadata to the to
the data block the other thing that is
required in order to make the data
accessible is all of the data that
exists within you know GCS pocket so on
at the bakery so we launched their crop
matter stove right so this is it's based
on high - - so this will allow you to
vegetative the data structured data
specific theory so that you can create
using spark presto or hive right so this
is another system that basically a lot
that allows you to bring more of
metadata and organize it in a way that
is variable now is the metadata
technical metadata has been registered
there are various tools that are
available on GCP to actually process you
have cloud in the top which is hosted
managed a tip I would say and then you
have 12 data flow which is provides your
civilus deeper processing paradigm for
good batch entry of time and then you
have bakery which has the query engine
as part of it that allows you to run
analytics right in real time on the data
that's been ingested a lot of machining
techniques that for example they can be
pretty much integrated very much
integrated into base very and there are
also approaches for the connected with
material that sits on GCS so now
bringing in all these together like when
you look at it there are various
different aspects right right now still
exists that you would have to spend a
little bit more time connecting them
together first you would have to catalog
only idea while in the data in the query
automatically
gender in India catalog there is some
amount of effort required in cataloging
all of the data that exists within the
cloud storage system now when you think
about meta store which is which is a new
addition to the cloud
DCP family it provides the much-awaited
technical metadata registration for such
India that allows the data to be now
exposed with the most popular
open-source tools which can again be run
on Terra so all of these reduce
different technologies or services that
we have on TCP let's start with storage
first so how do people use the GCS right
people the size of GCS has been delayed
some customers do that and some
customers will be query as the data and
that's okay both do provide the boot do
have advantages and disadvantages but
the both can be used as the base storage
layer for a data link
most customers end up bringing to the
GCP using various suggestion tools and
processing systems it's not just limited
to whatever GCP provides you could have
tracer on friend members providing
capabilities that allow you to bring the
data you can use any other services to
bring the data into GCP now you have a
language ECP the pattern that we
observed is as the data goes through
various different forms of processing
one of the primary destination for this
data the clans on GCS is Picard and
that's where most of the analytics end
up happening because as you guys on
Vickery is that you have a house offered
from which is offered by JCP
now when you look at like from a big way
as a Dean of a house the data that gets
moved into bigquery is optimized for
handles from the beginning from the
start as soon as you pour the data into
bigquery it's optimized for analytics
now the way it very stores it's the
internal format is very much optimized
in the sense pardoning a large scale
analytics and data and we have customers
that who stores petabytes of data and
analyzed all of that the United seconds
now one of the differences between
bigquery and GCS is bigquery the data
has to be structured or semi structured
so you can store JSON and you can throw
those kind of data types to see the
query but GCS yesterday and you can have
images you can have audio files you can
have pretty much anything you want us to
be stored on a GCS now let's look at
let's go a little bit further and look
at what are the differences between us
right
I want to be careful I think depends on
what you know compared to GCS declared
now has optimized with you know fixed
locks and all those things it basically
gives you a lot more optimization from
that perspective right but the major
difference that exists between GCS and
bigquery is the schema for bigquery has
to be defined a priori it has to the
schema hat it has to be known but if you
see s case it doesn't need to be they
can actually store just the past and
they can define the scheme a great time
the common data sources for all of the
data that exists in GCS is like a file
formats any data type it doesn't matter
structure unstructured semi-structured
data all chemistro now most particularly
is used from a relational and
transactional databases but as you can
imagine there are also some a structured
data that cannot exist within the
database for example you know they can
be some of the commedia so all of that
not specifically example per Jason can
be representative within the query since
the primary users when you look at it
from perspective of these two different
services top storage you know data
engineers anyone who can read and write
a file can basically access
and in victory anyone who can play
degree which has mostly data analysts
business analysts and even data
engineers right so pretty much everyone
on the planet knows how to write a query
so they cannot they can use pretty
quickly in then sense the data is a
little bit structure and they would have
to understand how to write a query which
is which is very common these days right
now so anyone can read that it's the
only difference being is the data is
very much structured in bigquery NVIDIA
is not a tall structure in GCS now but I
mean structure it's representation of
you know the technical metric which is
let the columns and the types and those
kind of things not the file is an
organization of those files so these are
these GCS and bigquery storage because
the foundation for any data rate that
you're building so depending on your use
cases you would have to make a choice if
you want to start with GCS or do you
want to territorial and that if I mean
to bigquery and that becomes your kiddo
big storage now when you think about in
cases there might be in a few cases
customers still want to land the data in
GCS and progressive through in GCS and
then lower only the data that is
required and curated for analytics into
bigquery for business hours now that we
have looked at storage options let us
look at the catalog and metadata options
the catalog and the metadata options
systematics stored now as you guys all
know data catalog provides a central
catalog across GCP
for showing all of the metadata and
indexing the metadata and making it much
more access through a storage interface
right so the interesting part of all of
this is it also adds on to ability to
create softer data governance
capabilities integrated as part of it so
you can use data Oona's templates to
categorize various different data assets
within the catalog so right now this is
very deeply integrated with from the
query perspective but there is you know
in the future that might be integration
automatically being provided from GCS
but
perspective but in the meantime you
would have to have a system that can
analyze fit all of the metadata that
exists on GCS and populate that into the
catalog so auto-tagging dia beta so this
is basically using DLP data loss
prevention as yet another it's another
service of DCP that allows you to
analyze the data and identify any of the
sensitive data that exists within that
if there is any PII data it will not
attack that PII data and suffice that
the administrators to once identify the
data catalog also provides the ability
where you have the ability to control
who has access to what metadata some of
the data is important the metadata
associated with that also is very
important so having ability to provide
access to troll over metadata is
critical capability that provides as you
all know the kinds of metadata that
exists technical business and
operational mandatory done so we are
talking about a business metadata and
this is also incorporating some of the
technical metadata but this is not from
from the viewpoint of processing this is
just for making the data accessible to
you and making it easier to access now
the next one is more focusing on how do
you take technical metadata and just do
that with the meta stowed that allows
you to make it makes it accessible then
that data becomes accessible to open
source tools that exists within these
two system so they rock metal stores
it's a newly launched service it's a
fully managed highly available open
source leader Apache have met a store
service which simplifies technical
metadata management right all of the
technical metadata that exists and that
gets registered within the data prop
matters too is now accessible to spark
hi presto notebooks
all these tools that are popular in open
source ready
have ready access to the data that
exists in the lake now it's an alpha
feature you should please go take it for
a spin and give it a try and let us know
is there things that you would like to
see improve on it and but it's a great
addition to the truth to telling the
truth story of academic transition it
provides a simplified management metis
to it even comes out with faster so you
can configure QC and do all those kind
stuff it provides the versioning
capability and it's all integrated into
the standard console of GCPs
so you get a fully managed experience
for managing one or more meta stores in
your great now that we have talked about
you know the the storage and the
metadata we can look at the other
components that exist within within the
lake for you know critical components
that exist within two lakes now data
exploration analysis is an important
aspect of it now because we talked about
registering the metadata and with the
approximate restore you should be able
to as soon as you bring the data and you
want to do some kind of an exploratory
analysis you should be able to use you
know tools like higher to query the data
now the dealer because it is registered
with five you'll be able to redeem the
query the data that using a high or spa
right from right from the console now
because of the launch of data proc
notebooks the notebooks are also
integrated with all of this D I'm making
exploratory analysis much more easier
and fun right so you don't have to have
a separate system you don't have to
manage it all by yourself it's all
managed within
didn't take a proc and makes it
extremely easy to get access to all of
the data that then gets registered with
the near proc understood there's a
process where you would have data that
already exists on GCS and not
with the high pedestal you would have to
do that manner you like I have a little
to that before but that's that's
something that in the future we might
basically make it automatic automatic
but right now you have to write
something little and just pull all of
that stuff and put it in there and put
it in there now for one of the use cases
that I talked about right so you want to
have a deity to spread the data a bit
feel like enough for example between
bigquery and GCS now the interesting
thing is having Fed rate varies between
them so bigquery has recently launched
the ability to query the data using
federated tables so you can define that
as an external table for the data that's
sitting on GCS and part a part of the
data could be in bigquery you can join
you can do all normal operations that
you can do with the table can be done
with federated queries so here it's a
simple process of resisting now wouldn't
it be cool if all of the data that sits
on GCS and any other system
automatically gets registered in too
high and gets represented as an external
table and bigquery so that any tools
that exist in the ecosystem can use the
metadata that is being registered to
query the data and make it immediately
access to so the data it doesn't have to
end up being a cypher in storage but
more may be much more accessible through
these ecosystem tools that are basically
providing a traditional service from a
registration of material perspective so
transformations we have talked about
when you build a lake yes
you want to have the ability to
transform your data you want the ability
to do complex transformations on it but
we have never seen I have at least I
have never seen a simple job that's
earning the delays it's a complex
network of hundreds of jobs that are
actually running in a rake in many
enterprises and in order to control all
of them
all of that you do that's what you need
the ability to run the job to do the
transformation so you can use data truck
you can use so data flow is a service
offering for passengers stream
processing and data is basically
supporting both loop and spa to
workloads
now what do we need to do for this is to
be able to take these two things
together and orchestrate them using
cloud proposal so while I can
essentially create jobs I want to be
able to you know stitch them together in
a bag and that can be done with
composure in addition to this you can of
course look at data fusion as a way of
doing transformations but there Ephesian
underneath uses their property and
provides a visual it's an innovation it
provides an ability to do the similar
stuff on top of it where you don't need
to have any programming you can just do
it in a good feedback right so all of
these things storage the metadata the
transformation now the last thing that
is required is the ability to do bring
all of the data integration aspects and
the ability to look at the lineage
end-to-end because when you look at how
the data flows within tearily alright so
while you idea provides advanced
transformation capabilities data
integration like data fusion provides
much more and managed ETL solution with
no or no for detail pipelines
right so you need to also have ingested
template and just templates for we need
the beta n so you should be able to you
know if you look at as an example of DTS
which you transfer service it provides
you a very simple form that allows you
to look at you know select a source
select a destination be able to just
copy the data over into the target right
so you need to have the ability to do
simple ingestion and the dirac should
not limit only for the usage of you
should be able to any use any form of
so we have customers who use informatica
people use time people use multi nian
debris the data here and there they
basically eat chili here you can use as
an option you can use data fusion to do
that but can you also use the Ephesian
for doing additional transformations if
you like and deploy them right like all
the data that it's generated is it gets
deployed back into the lake or can be
pushed into the data warehouse now one
of the important things from a larger
enterprise perspective is ability to
keep track of the data as it flows
through the system so you need to have a
good understanding of how the data is
flowing in your lake so you need to have
a good lineage capability right well
this des capability right now exists
only in data fusion in the future we
will be looking at making that available
as part of the data catalog and once
it's there you will be able to look at
lineage across the whole end-to-end from
that perspective from a GCD perspective
for any dealer right that exists now the
only limitation of the current lineage
is that if you use the diffusion only
then that we need to present the lineage
is available at two levels one is at
leadership level which tells you what a
job
processing worked on what leader set and
what are the resulting data sets that we
generated the second is be able to look
at the field level the field level will
give you much more granular information
of how an individual field was generated
and what were the various different data
sets that were connected to it to
generate the resulting
field from those operations right so you
need this this will provide from a
compliance auditing a very targeted
ability it provides an end-to-end
solution to the best possible delayed
right so now that we have looked at
various different aspects of T domain
right so we have looked at what are the
different storage mechanisms we have in
the late what are the different you know
metadata systems they have whatever
various different in transformation
systems we have and how do you do
from an education leaders perspective so
billion-dollar together right now is a
task it's something that they would have
to do yourself but you know in the
future we are providing all these
different integrations with various
services to make the life of building
Dino makes much more easier so it should
be very easy for you to just take all of
these integrated set of services and
build makes in our goal is to make it as
fast as you can right like right now
right now it probably makes you teach
your months so if we should be able to
reduce that down to you know with all
these tool indications that end up
happening it should come down to like
you know a few days now to summarize as
we found in the top building data lakes
is extremely hard
now GCP provides all of the necessary
services to build the best database you
can possibly have as you can also see
all of the innovation that is happening
within GCP to pay the best integrated
parts as an example they query now
integrate with data that exists on GCS
allowing you to federated data across
the query on GCS in addition to
completing the story for dinner length
we are closing a lot of different gaps
department store is another such service
that just got launched that provides
your ability to integrate metadata and
make it accessible open source tools and
these are some of the capabilities that
exist on in GCP then you can leverage to
build the best make possible give it a
try thank you so much